[Musik]
hallo ihr lieben horchheimer dem
herzlich willkommen zu meinem
afghanischen gericht das erste
afghanischer bericht was überhaupt auf
dem kanal gibt und ich freue mich schon
sehr denn wir machen endlich den kabul
ihr eis den habe ich schon oft gar nicht
noch zeiten gegessen und jetzt habe ich
mir gedacht ich zeige euch die
zubereitung von dem leckeren kabul ihrer
ist während meiner suche für das
perfekte kabul ihr rezept habe ich meine
afghanischen freundin gefragt und aber
auch von hand aus afghanischen freunden
die mama vielen dank noch mal an die
mama von walid und weiß für das rezept
ich habe jetzt nicht genau das rezept
genommen sondern ich habe mir wirklich
das beste aus allem zusammengestellt
denn ich muss sagen der kapo die rechte
hat echt in sich aber vertraut mir nach
diesem rezept gelingt euch der
hundertprozentig das ist mein
versprechen an euch und jetzt zeige ich
euch aber zuallererst die zutaten die
wir benötigen wir benötigen was marty
reis und zwar ist es ganz wichtig ist
die bezeichnung zelle erträgt zeller ist
jetzt keine marke sondern einfach nur
die bezeichnung vom reise es gibt da
mehrere marken schaut einfach mal nach
und ich habe ihn jetzt drei stunden lang
einweichen lassen in lauwarmes
kaltwasser und bei zimmertemperatur
stehen lassen
außerdem benötigen wir lamm aus der
keule neutrales hören die habe ich
bereits in solche stifter geschnitten
prosieben hier habe ich korinthen
genommen und dafür auch noch mal zucker
außerdem zwiebeln und salz pfeffer
kurkuma und gummi und außerdem später
erneut etwas zucker der kabul ihr eis
zeichnet sich dadurch aus dass die
möhren und die rosinen karamellisiert
werden das heißt wir geben jetzt öl in
die pfanne und braten dann die möhren
darin an und später gehen wir auf den
zucker dazu
[Musik]
die möhren sind jetzt bei mir fünf
minuten lang angeboten worden und jetzt
gehen wir den zucker rein und lassen den
ganz langsam schmelzen es dort noch mal
etwa ein bis zwei minuten
[Musik]
nach den zwei minuten nehmen wir jetzt
die kanalisierte möhren raus und ich
gebe euch noch den tipp schneidet sie
bloß nicht zu dünn
denn die werden ja so noch weich und
nicht dass ihr euch dann reißen oder
kaputt gehen
in den restlichen öl zucker gemischt
werden jetzt noch die rosinen angebraten
und ihr könnt es übrigens nicht beide
zusammen beraten falls euch das jetzt
fragt wenn der mal verschiedene brat
zeiten
[Musik]
die rosinen haben jetzt ganze zwei
minuten gebraucht also etwas kürzer als
die möhren und das öl was sie noch in
der pfanne ist das gebe ich jetzt zwar
an die seite um die fahne erneut zu
benutzen aber ich schütte es noch nicht
weg denn es kann sein dass das gleich
noch weiter verwenden werden so als
nächstes kümmern wir uns um das fleisch
und außerdem auch um so ein bisschen
geschmack mit den gewürzen es gibt sie
zuallererst in meine fahne fleisch und
zwiebel und überließen das dann mit
etwas wasser
für den kabul ihr eis ist es ganz normal
und traditionell dass man hier
lammfleisch verwendet jetzt gebe ich
ganz offen und ehrlich zu haben sind
nicht so die lammfleisch fans wirklich
nicht aber ich hab's ja schon mal probe
gekocht und das war wirklich lecker also
nimmt auf jeden fall lammfleisch aus der
keule die superreichen wunder dass der
hansa lammfleisch ist weil ich glaube zu
hause werden wir jetzt auch nicht so
gerne auf jeden fall habe ich jetzt das
fleisch schon mal bearbeiten nach dem
vom metzger das ist optimal wenn er das
so machen können lasst die knochen
entfernen und die überschüssige haut und
das fett und dann haben sie zuhause halt
nur noch in etwas größer als
mundgerechte stücke geschnitten und zu
den zwiebeln kann ich euch sagen ich
nehme sich später heraus ich gibt sie
dann später nur so nebenbei als beilage
zum reiss weil es nicht gerne im reis
habe ihr könnt es aber auch noch kleiner
stein die zwiebel und dann ist es halt
mit im reich bei euch das ist vollkommen
euch überlassen
nun kocht das ganze und es braucht so
ungefähr zwölf bis 15 minuten ist kommt
auch immer ganz drauf an wie ticker
fleisch ist ihr müsst dann einfach mal
schauen wann es durch ist und ich gebe
aber jetzt schon die gewürze mit hinzu
salz und pfeffer geben sprechen zu ich
habe ich aber noch ganz genau wie viel
salz er immer für diesen schritt braucht
und wie viel für den reis und zum
kurkuma kann ich sagen gebt ihnen auch
mit dazu für die farbe auch wenn wir
gleich noch mit dem nachhelfen mit der
farbe das zeige ich euch nachher zum
gummi noch ein ganz kleiner einwand ich
habe jetzt hier kommen also gemahlin
kreuzkümmel genommen es ist aber
traditionell dass man gar am us dollar
nimmt und sogar es gibt sogar ein extra
afghanisches reis gehört ich weiß aber
dass diese zutaten sehr schwer zu finden
sind und deshalb gebe ich euch den tipp
mit den kommunen also ihr könnt
ersatzweise definitiv dieses gewürz
nehmen
[Musik]
15 minuten sind um und jetzt hole ich
fleisch und zwiebeln aus der restlichen
brühl raus also ich persönlich werde
jetzt zwiebeln von fleisch trennen weil
die gleich möchte jetzt die zwiebeln
nicht in dem kap rudi reitz drin
falls ihr das aber so macht das in dem
die zwiebel mit drin haben möchtet dann
könnt ihr das ganze natürlich auch durch
einen sieg geben wenn diese flüssigkeit
diese brühe die jetzt noch hier drin ist
die ist ganz wichtig die benötigen wir
später noch die völlig gleich um und
dann geht es weiter mit dem reis
[Musik]
den reis habe ich wie gesagt einweichen
lassen drei stunden lang hier auf
zimmertemperatur
hier sieht man auch dass das wasser ganz
trüb ist und die stärkere so langsam
allmählich heraus gekommen aus dem reis
jetzt ganz kurz ein spülbecken geht das
wasser ab und dann zeige ich euch wie es
weitergeht
das wasser habe ich jetzt abgegossen und
den reis auch nochmal abgespült das
machen wir im vergleich sowieso noch mal
aber sicher ist sicher dann ist wirklich
die ganze stärke raus jetzt geht es in
kochendes salzwasser und da wird der
reis gekocht also nicht gekauft sondern
wirklich gekocht und zwar zehn minuten
und da muss auch noch nicht ganz klar
sein denn das machen wir später noch im
nächsten schritt
[Musik]
während jetzt in diesem topf der reist
zehn minuten vor sich hin köchelt nutzen
die zeit und den rüber an die
beschichtete pfanne geben da unseren
zucker rein und lassen uns ganz langsam
schmelzen und karamellisieren können wir
darüber reden das haben sie ein buch
gelesen hat und das einzige buch was
haben sie gelesen habt war einst was aus
einer geschichte aus afghanistan stammt
nämlich drachenläufer repositories ok
drache war war ich ein schönes buch und
der film also der film auch wunderschön
und ganze angerissen
ja ja der was der film ein bisschen
anders als die geschichte logistischen
schlusshoch seit sommer in die
kommentare ob ihr das auch gelesen oder
geschaut wird nicht mal sehr
interessieren
[Musik]
mein zucker ist jetzt karamellisiert und
zwar bei mittlerer stufe ganz langsam
und jetzt geben wir die brühe von gerade
rein und jetzt müsst ihr ganz vorsichtig
sein denn es ist saugefährlich also
nimmt ein bisschen abstand ich meine es
ernst mit ein bisschen abstand und dann
gebt ihr ganz langsam die brühe rein und
was das unter ständigem rühren damit
verschmelzt und ich muss es morgen und
du musst nach ankommen genau vorlegen
übrigens ist es ganz normal dass ich
hier klümpchen bilden dass sie ganz
einfach daran dass er so diesen
temperaturausgleich jetzt nicht habt das
heißt karamell war ziemlich heißt und
die früher die villa in der zwischenzeit
schon heruntergekühlt und deswegen
bilden sich da die klümpchen einfach auf
mittlerer stufe immer weiter rühren bis
sich das ganze wieder auflöst
übrigens sorgt dieses produkt hier was
wir hier aus karamell und brühe
hergestellt haben gleich nochmal für die
farbe und natürlich für den geschmack
ihr könnt gerne an der show noch ein
bisschen salz also nachwürzen und falls
ihr möchtet könnt ihr auch noch ein
bisschen wasser hinzugeben denn denkt
dran durch diese brühe die hier noch ist
gar der reis gleich nochmal
[Musik]
übrigens keine panik leute ich weiß in
diesem video rede ich ein bisschen mehr
wolltest du gemein weil das ist einfach
ein bisschen anspruchsvoller und da gibt
es einiges zu beachten aber keine panik
ist es trotzdem gelingen sicher ich
schreibe euch alles wichtige in der
infobox also auch tipps und tricks
schaut er deshalb unbedingt noch mal
rein
so ich schalte den herd aus dass es
erledigt und in der zwischenzeit ist
meine reise aufgekocht und jetzt gehe
ich ihnen ganz kurz abspielen im
spülbecken den reif habe ich jetzt
unterspülen im kalten wasser richtig gut
ausgespielt damit auch überhaupt keine
stärke mehr drin ist und der reißt
dadurch richtig schön locker wird und
jetzt gehen wir den zurück in unserem
topf und diesmal habe ich aber kein
wasser drin
[Musik]
zudem reis geben wir jetzt noch unsere
brühe und rühren das gut unter
[Musik]
und genau deshalb haben wir das ganze
gemacht dieser karamellisiertem zucker
mit der brühe
er gibt dem ganzen nämlich nicht nur
geschmack sondern auch diese
traditionelle typische farbe
sobald ihr das jetzt gut untergerührt
und jedes reiskorn farbe angenommen hat
bildet ihr in der mitte eine mulde und
gibt das fleisch da rein
[Musik]
und dann geben wir reif darüber und
bedecken das komplette fleisch sobald
detail mit dem fleisch erledigt ist
geben wir noch hören und rosinen dazu
das sind einfach dazu dass es gleich
alles richtig schön warm wird der reise
ist jetzt durch das ausspülen auch noch
kalt aber das wird gleich nach dem gern
auch noch richtig schön aufgewärmt
[Musik]
jetzt kommt der allerletzte schritt und
zwar wieder reich jetzt noch ganz
langsam 10 bis 15 minuten gegart ganz
wichtig ist jetzt noch folgendes es gibt
jetzt den deckel drauf aber mit einem
geschirrtuch darunter das team einfach
dazu dass wenn der dampf hoch steigt das
bild das die tropfen nicht wieder runter
fallen und quasi der reise richtig
locker bleibt und dadurch nicht matschig
wird
[Musik]
meine reise sind schön aufgewärmt und
fertig ich zeige euch auf den
allerletzten schritt aber vorher muss
ich euch noch einen trick zeigen damit
auch kein afghane sagt ich habe euch
nicht gezeigt denn es gibt einige die
nehmen sich jetzt zum beispiel hier so
den stil eines kochlöffels und gehen
dann noch mal rein und machen dann so
ein paar löcher hinein das team einfach
dazu dass es noch mal richtig schön hoch
steigen kann alles bei mir muss ich es
nicht machen ihr könnt aber gerne tun
wenn euch das besser hilft willi mit
zuallererst die rosinen und die möhren
raus und dann zeige ich euch noch mal
was sie mit dem öl machen was wir noch
vom anfang übrig hatten
[Musik]
und jetzt wird alles gut umgerührt das
öl was du uns am anfang an die seite
gegeben haben das habe ich jetzt noch
mal erhitzt und gebe ich jetzt mit zum
reiss
[Musik]
und so wird der kabuler ist angerichtet
auf einem schönen großen teller und dann
nimmt sich einfach jeder was weg ich
hoffe natürlich dass ich das rezept
gefällt und dass ihr das fleißig nach
macht die genauen mengenangaben schreibe
ich euch wie immer unten die infobox ich
weiß es sein aufwand aber es lohnt sich
denn der schmeckt unglaublich lecker ich
freue mich wenn ihr beim nächsten mal
auch wieder einschaltet hinterlassen wir
gerne euer feedback und in den
kommentaren abonniert den kanal damit
ihr nichts mehr verpasst und dann sage
ich bis zum nächsten mal auf die gis
kitchen tschüss
[Musik]